un nuevo revés para la oposición
venezolana el tribunal supremo de
justicia anunció que las elecciones
regionales en barinas deberán repetirse
pues consideró que el candidato opositor
freddy superlano está inhabilitado para
ejercer cargos públicos el político
había conseguido un estrecho margen de
votos de ventaja en los comicios del 21
de noviembre frente argenis chávez el
hermano del ex presidente hugo chávez
ocho días de recuento en los que los dos
candidatos tenían una corta diferencia
que nos superaban los mil votos según
las proyecciones del consejo nacional
electoral superando tenía 37 6 por
ciento de los votos y chávez 37 punto 21
la decisión del máximo tribunal vino
tras recibir una acción de amparo
impuesta por adolfo ramón superlano
disidente de la oposición el tsj ordena
al consejo nacional electoral convocar
para el día 9 de enero de 2022 las
elecciones de gobernador o gobernadora
del estado de barinas superlano catalogó
la determinación del tsj como injusta en
conversación con france24
nosotros pues fui muy insultado por el
presidente del todo exacto nicolás
maduro el 31 de agosto del año pasado no
por hechos de abril de 2019 para sin
embargo el propio ente electoral es
quien recibe nuestra postulación para
ser candidato y cuando hay una persona
inhabilitada automáticamente los rechaza
cosa que no pasó con nosotros que no
solamente no postulamos participamos
ganamos la elección por su parte argenis
chávez renunció a ser candidato y dejó
su actual cargo de gobernador a una
falta de un mes para acabar su mandato
el triunfo en barinas la tierra natal de
hugo chávez era esperanzadora para una
oposición derrotada en 19 de 23
gobernaciones